Within your fingertips are many sensors
feeding you information on the tactile world
grip, friction, pressure -
all these things you need to pick up a pen
or feel bumps on a piece of paper.
Now researchers have created a synthetic system that
captures many aspects of this biological feat.
This “neuromorphic” system uses flexible electronics
to sense and report on tactile information
Classic computers get along by crunching
large amounts of 1s and 0s
which can add up to a lot of energy consumption.
We can’t have our brains
getting hot like an overworked laptop
so our bodies have a super efficient way
of dealing with a barrage of input.
For example --
there is pressure on many sensors on the skin,
those signals are funneled to a single neuron
that, if it reaches a certain threshold,
triggers a response that passes the message on.
Signals from these neurons converge
on the next layer up, which
integrates the information further with other sources.
Here’s how the artificial neuron replicates biology:
Touching the pressure sensor increases the
electrical voltage between a pair of electrodes
in the sensor.
That extra voltage is used by a neighboring device,
called a ring oscillator,
to create a string of electrical pulses.
Those pulses, and ones from neighboring rings,
are then sent to a third device,
called a synaptic transistor,
which integrates the incoming signals and generates its
own series of pulses
depending on the pattern it receives.
For example, applying steady soft pressure
produces a series of pulses at a different rate
than applying more forceful pressure.
Researchers showed they could use their sensors
to detect the placement and motion of a small rod
and detect a braille pattern.
They even sent the output pulses to an electrode
inserted in a detached leg of a cockroach
and showed that the insect’s nervous system
could receive the pulses and move the leg in response.
None of these parts are particularly new.
But using them to generate responses
to tactile information is.
In the future, cheap and efficient systems like these
could create large arrays of sensors for prosthetics.
And these types of circuits can aid in building robots
that can sense and respond to the environment.
It’s fine to have a preprogrammed bot build a car
but when it needs to respond to changes
in the world around i --including moving people--
the more senses the better.